hi this is fresh talker can you solve
this problem which went viral in Japan a
recent test found that only 60 percent
of Japanese 20 year olds were able to
get the correct answer this is alarming
because it's down from 90% which was the
accuracy rate in the 1980s can you
figure it out
to get started I'm going to go over a
common mistake many people will input
this expression into Google or into a
calculator in order to do so you have to
convert the fraction 1/3 into an inline
expression many people write out the
equation in the following form now you
you would interpret the 1/3 as being
grouped together however I would
discourage you from writing expressions
in this form it's not clear that the 1/3
should be grouped together because this
expression uses both a division symbol
in a division / which are the same
mathematical operation of division
although you want the 1/3 to be grouped
together this expression is going to be
evaluated by a calculator by converting
this division symbol into a division /
this will not be equal to your original
expression the calculator is going to
look at the 3 divided by 1/3 as one term
and it's going to evaluate it from left
to right it's going to evaluate the 3
divided by one first then is going to
divide 3 divided by 3 and then it's
going to do 9 minus 1 plus 1 which will
give you a result of 9 if you were to
transcribe it on a calculator you want
to make sure that the fraction of 1/3
maintains group together so instead of
writing this expression you would like
to write an expression which groups the
1/3 as one group now a calculator will
properly evaluate this 1/3 and this
whole term 3 divided by 1/3
in the proper order three divided by
one-third is equal to nine and now we
have nine minus 9 plus one which gives
us the correct answer of 1 the problem
is a good reminder about the order of
operations
these can be remembered by the acronyms
PEMDAS or baud moss this relates to the
order of operations of parentheses
brackets exponents orders then
multiplication division and finally
addition subtraction another important
rule is that if you have if you have
operators of the same precedence you
want to evaluate the expression from
left to right so let's get to that we
have no parentheses or brackets in this
expression we also have no exponents or
orders we do have a division here which
is 3 divided by 1/3 so let's evaluate
this first 3 divided by 1/3 is the same
thing as 3 multiplied by the reciprocal
of 1/3 which is 3 we now have a
multiplication of 3 times 3 which we
also evaluate before anything else 3
times 3 is equal to 9 and now we have an
expression with only addition and
subtraction so how do you evaluate this
expression how do you know what to do
well if you have something of the same
precedence addition and subtraction you
want to evaluate the expression from
left to right so we'll first evaluate 9
minus 9 which gives us 0 then you
evaluate 0 plus 1 which gives us the
correct answer of 1 did you figure it
out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel and make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch me on social
media at pressure Walker and if you
liked this video please check out my
books there links in the video
description